we are so lucky ladies and gentlemen
because we have the undisputed king of
the red carpet with us tonight mr billy
porter
yeah
now
i've got this the famous picture from
from the oscars of you in that amazing
tuxedo
is this where your red carpet journey
began
yeah you know i've always been into
fashion i grew up in the black church in
america
it's a fashion show
you know it is you know i'm
first-generation post-civil rights
movement it was always about what you
look like so fashion you know my
grandmother used to make the vogue
patterns and everything so i remember
being in drama school and you know
talking to my friends and being like i'm
gonna wear a gown to the oscars you know
the boys are so boring they they're in
the same penguin suit every time i'm not
gonna do that and
it just resonated with me and i was like
if there's anybody
who would understand how to do that you
know my thought was if the camera starts
close right and it's here yeah it will
look like
a tuxedo and then when it pulls out
it'll be a full gag because i want a
full-on antebellum
you know yeah ball gown
and
we did it
and
when i say it's like
the oscar dress
that resonated across the world and
changed the conversation for everybody
forever that is not what i was expecting
that is not the reason why i did it and
simultaneously i knew that the oscars
had the power because it's our
super bowl it's like i knew that the
eyes on it would have the power to sort
of
do something or transform something you
know and we have to be our own business
people you know it's show business right
yeah and this was a moment that
for me
[Music]
sort of solidified
i actually know what the [ __ ] i'm doing
yeah
i did that on purpose it was intentional
yeah and it worked you know there were a
lot of people who were like oh you're
just trying to get attention you know
the the haters on on it's i'm an actor
yeah
i'm trying to get your attention
[Applause]
[Music]